un amas de tôle froissée calcinés c'est
tout ce qui reste d'un petit appareil de
type ulm qui s'est écrasé cet après midi
sur la commune de vinzelles arrivés très
vite sur place les pompiers ont éteint
un début d'incendié mais n'ont pas pu
accéder au pilote un homme âgé qui avait
décollé de l'aérodrome de
charnay-lès-mâcon d'après le témoignage
qui nous a été rapporté l'avion tout
d'un coup a plongé vers le sol et est
venu à priori percuté les caténaires
avant de s'écraser en bordure de ballast
donc ça peut être l'hypothèse soit
d'un malaise soit d'un incident
technique les conditions météo sont
bonnes donc voilà pour l'instant
après il faut que l'enquêté se poursuit
pour en savoir plus mais a priori c'est
une thèse accidentelle
la gendarmerie des transports aériens de
mulhouse été saisie de l'enquêté
le petit et rosneft devrait être enlevée
dans la soirée et par précaution compte
tenu des lieux du crash
le trafic ferroviaire entre lyon et
mâcon était interrompue de longues
heures avant d'être rétablie
partiellement et ponctuellement